nous sommes allés dîner avec les
comédiens les copains il a pris ma main
comme ça de nouveau et il m'a dit je
t'épouse
ce soir ma chère
[Applaudissements]
en 1964 il y a donc exactement 50 ans
Macha vous êtes une étoile montante de
la Nouvelle Vague Michel vous venez de
décrocher la palme d'or à Cannes avec
Les Parapluies de Cherbourg et vos
chemins se croisent lors d'un festival
de cinéma sur la plage de Copacabana à
Rio c'est le coup de foudre
malheureusement vous devrez attendre 5
décennies avant de pouvoir consommer cet
amour aujourd'hui à respectivement 82 et
74 ans vous venez de vous marier vous
nous rencontrer notre histoire à 20h
peut-être
[Musique]
et Michel Legrand
alors
il y a un son et lumière qu'on utilise
dans cette émission quand on parle
d'amour avec nos invités
toutes les semaines c'est pas vrai dès
qu'il y a une histoire d'amour c'est ça
et voilà tu te rends compte je trouve
que c'est particulièrement bien choisi
ce soir puisque vous êtes là pour vous
c'est un Oscar l'un de vos trois Oscars
[Musique]
on pense à vous toutes les semaines
alors Macha Méril vous êtes né le 3
septembre 1940 à Rabat au Maroc de
parents aristocrates russes exilé après
la révolution bolchevique de 1917 vous
êtes princesse Macha lorsque votre père
meurt du typhus en 1947 votre mère
quitte le Maroc pour la France
et là vous vivez à Paris une adolescence
fauchée bohème et nocturne
années quand même parce que il y avait
cette émigration russe
il faut se rappeler que c'était tous les
artistes du cinéma du théâtre de la
musique ils étaient tous russes alors le
bac en poche vous faites vos débuts à 19
ans dans la main chaude le premier film
de Gérard Oury ensuite vous bossez avec
Godard avec Bunuel avec piala avec face
Bender avec Lelouch vous faites une
carrière au théâtre et en librairie vous
publiez six romans trois récits
autobiographiques et 4 livres de cuisine
voilà alors Michel Legrand vous êtes né
le 24 février 1932 à Paris votre père
c'est le chef d'orchestre Raymond
Legrand un jour vous avez trois ans il
part chercher des allumettes il revient
pas
et vous le retrouverez 15 ans plus tard
en fait vous serez très lié et quand il
était en studio et qu'il avait une
partition à terminer vous appelez pour
que ce soit prêt à l'heure et alors il y
a eu un moment très important dans votre
vie Michel c'est le jour où vous voyez
un film sur la vie de Schubert avec Tino
Rossi dans le rôle titre et là vous
dites une pluie de phrase musicale
sublime tomber des nuages c'était la
côte avec un petit une petite plume noir
il écrit quelques notes sur un parchemin
4 il dirige alors
c'est facile c'est rien formidable
alors après le Conservatoire donc vous
entamez une prodigieuse carrière faut
bien le dire dès 1956 avec I love Paris
vous séduisez les Américains 8 millions
de disques vendus quand vous passez à la
télé à ce moment-là il y a 30 millions
de téléspectateurs devant le poste c'est
quand même
j'ai fait avec Paris chevalier à propos
de i love Paris j'ai fait la première
émission en couleur du monde mais c'est
vrai que vous étiez le directeur musical
de Maurice Chevalier
ensuite il y a le cinéma évidemment vous
travaillez avec Varda vous travaillez
Godard et puis les parapluies de
Cherbourg de Jacques Demy vous inventez
tous les deux la comédie musicale à la
française en fait Théo les dialogues
sont chantés je vous remercie beaucoup
parce que quand j'ai vu les parapluies
de charbon j'étais
un des plus gros moment de ma vie
ensuite alors évidemment carrière
internationale
l'affaire Thomas Crown dont est issu la
chanson Les Moulins de mon cœur vous
avez un Oscar vous un Oscar aussi pour
un été 42 pour Yann tel babas 13 ans
enfin bref vous êtes un génie Michel et
là en 1974 lors d'un festival de cinéma
à copagabonda sur la plage vous
rencontrez Masha et vous allez danser
tous les deux nous avions
mitoko qui nous a dit le soir il faut
que vous veniez écouter de la musique et
comme nous tous les deux nous étions des
gens qui ont le jazz on y allait dans
des boîtes invraisemblables dans les
favelas et nous on n'a pas dormi une
heure pendant ces quatre jours
il a un moment
en train de danser vous vous regardez
tous les deux et vous vous dites merde
on s'aime
[Rires]
incroyable
comment dire tellement évidente il y a
même pas se poser la question en
discuter ça se sent tout de suite on
s'est pris la main comme ça
et là alors commence trois nuits et
trois jours d'amour fulgurant mais son
sexe vous n'avez pas consommé la raison
était que on savait que c'était pas
possible et que donc il valait beaucoup
mieux que ça reste comme un rêve et que
ce soit pas une histoire conclue comme
si on avait prévu que peut-être un jour
on se retrouverait c'est vrai que Macha
vous vous allez vous marier Michel vous
êtes déjà vous avez un enfant enfin
c'est pas le bon moment et là vous
décidez de pas créer du malheur autour
de vous et vous reprenez le cours de vos
existences respectives et on se fait la
promesse de ne pas se rechercher et là
pendant décennies vous allez vous
croiser à plusieurs reprises sans jamais
céder à la tentation il veut juste un
petit pincement de coeur quand vous
rencontrez alors Michel vous marier une
deuxième fois le troisième fois
Macha vous vivez avec Diane bitorio
Baldy et pendant les années
70-80 90 vous Michel vous gardez quand
même la petite flamme en revanche vous
Macha vous effacez le truc ah oui c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible il faut
il faut il faut avancer il faut pas
s'ouvrir et puis je pense en plus que
tout de même si l'histoire d'un refus il
a pas divorcé pour vous ah quand même tu
m'avais pas dit ça auparavant c'est la
première fois que tu lances
bien sûr que tout est vrai mais c'était
au dessus de tout ça c'est-à-dire que
oui c'est vrai c'était pas écrit c'était
pas prêt c'était pas bien
non on aurait raté on aurait on aurait
pareil réussi et puis récemment début
2014 donc tout se réveille en une
seconde
Michel vient vous voir au théâtre et là
les retrouvailles sont fulgurantes alors
premièrement Michel venait de se séparer
de sa dernière compagne et moi j'étais
seule depuis deux ans dans une solitude
assez confortable absolument et puis il
se présente il me j'ai senti pendant que
je jouais ça ça va t'amuser Bérénice
pendant tout le spectacle je savais où
il était dans la salle j'ai senti ses
yeux il manque pas quitté pendant tout
le spectacle comme un laser qui me
regardait et à la fin nous sommes allés
dîner avec les comédiens les copains il
a pris ma main comme ça de nouveau
et il m'a dit je t'épouse
du calme du calme je dis quand même
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce jeune homme
exalté et c'était vrai alors l'âge de
notre liste quand même c'est qu'il faut
dire que au lit ça va bien et c'est non
mais c'est important ben voilà c'est
important parce que parce que oui ça
veut dire une chose ça veut dire qu'en
fait ce désir ne s'arrête jamais et ça
c'est très rassurant pour les gens de
mon âge mais la sexualité c'est de la
création alors en plus moi je vais
ajouter une chose je pense que l'amour
c'est pas une affaire de jeunes parce
que quand on est jeune il y a tellement
de trucs qu'il faut réaliser il faut
faire plaisir à la famille il faut faire
plaisir à la société il faut faire des
enfants il faut gagner sa vie il faut
bien les élever il faut s'épanouir il
faut réussir je sais pas comment il faut
rester drôle il faut rester sympathiques
c'est infaisable c'est pour ça que vous
n'y arrivez pas personne n'y arrive
tandis que nous on avait que pour nous
on est que pour l'amour
on est libre
c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est maintenant que je vis ma vraie
jeunesse mais ma folle jeunesse va
formidable jeunesse
il va pleurer
bon enfin bon vous vous mariez le 16
septembre 2014 à Monaco voilà tous les
deux les jeunes mariés
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu